according to Khloe Kardashian her sister
court is a total buzzkill Khloe I was
just thinking you complain a lot what do
I complain about on Monday koko hit up
Twitter to do what little sisters do
giving their big sisters attitude oh
here's what went down on Sunday Chloe
hit the town with Kourt and Kylie Jenner
for an Oscars after-party and on Monday
Khloe tweeted quote ah
why did Kylie and I allow Kourtney to
ruin our night last night ah when
neither court nor Kylie responded Chloe
simply added Oh Kourtney but it seems
the reality star was just giving her
sister a hard time because according to
their social media the crew had a lot of
fun does me know yes so much fun that
they pretended to eat Hawaiian rolls in
the back of the car anyway
Kourt Khloe and Kylie hit up beyonce and
jay z's exclusive Oscars after-party
where they met up with Kim and Kanye
first of all tell me about this girl
you forgot about it was actually one of
my Christmas presents Christmas et was
with Kim earlier in the night at the
Vanity Fair bash where she revealed the
secret behind her look he bought you a
couture gown for Christmas Alexander
McQueen 2003 it's his shipwreck dress so
I would always stress out about big
events like this and what would I wear
and the last-minute part of it and so he
kind of filled it up and got me a few
really nice couture pieces so that I
wouldn't stress out like Kylie was also
at the bash
[Music]
it's over thanks Roy
you shout out
she rocked the carpet in a sparkling
navy ralphing Russo dress but swapped it
out for this bright red off-the-shoulder
gown by Vivienne Westwood for party
number two she shared this pic of her
red-hot look on Instagram writing yes to
the dress
yeah yes to the dress yes to the
Lorraine Schwartz diamonds and a big
hell yes to those Christian Louboutin
nude heels right Kylie actually kicked
up those heels and rested her legs on
her sister in the back of the car and
just take a look at that epic family
portrait but also can we talk about the
fact that Kylie posted this clip to her
Instagram story - that's her ex and baby
daddy Travis in the back of the car with
the girls a source recently told ET
quote Kylie and Travis truly enjoy one
another and are in love but it can often
be hard navigating their lives at such a
young age
the couple needed to take a step back to
reevaluate many things but in doing so
they are better now than ever
cute okay but back to the fashion Chloe
looked fierce AF in a white
off-the-shoulder gown with a thigh high
and we mean high slit and an edgy blonde
bob Chloe is just so fun and in true
Kardashian fashion court praised her sis
in the comments on Instagram calling
Koko her gorgeous date we'd have a
proposal for you it starts with an F and
ends with a D the Kardashian sisters
seemed to be on better terms these days
following a tense season of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians where Kim and Khloe
straight-up threatened to fire cords for
not pulling her weight
everyone needs a time to play let's show
her if she doesn't want to show up she
doesn't want to work she has too many
boundaries she's out you mentioned that
you might be ready to say goodbye to
Keeping Up with the Kardashians where
are you at on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there but
I'm not saying goodbye right but I think
you'll have to see more of it on the new
season season 18 do you think the show
can continue going if you lose a sister
we definitely love portney and we will
miss Courtney and whatever she decides
to do but people come people go all the
time this family we are feel like it's a
revolving door
so Courtney might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back I know the
drama is good for ratings but man I
really like when these girls all just
get along
of course you can count on ET to help
you keep up with the Kardashians so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens
see you soon
[Music]